[Music]
right now
a new battle royale sits atop the gaming
world okay
i am getting royally [ __ ] that's
what's happening
but this isn't like any br you've seen
before scan this guy this guy
there's no guns stop dropping them
fruit drops from the sky the the easiest
way to win
fruit shoot right is just hug a wall
that's it ready watch
and instead of a person you play as a
jelly
jellybean
someone's grabbing me you [ __ ] idiot
this is my crown baby
wait for it no i didn't know that it
moved
do you ever hear a trap like this just
dive
works every time i'm talking about none
other than
fall guys full guys ultimate [ __ ]
knockout bro
but a launch date disaster almost caused
one of the biggest games on twitch
to fall flat
i can't shop fall guys is everyone's
newest gaming addiction
the mini game focused battle royale is
all anybody can talk about and it's
already
sold over 2 million copies it also set
up a hilarious and ridiculous adventure
with everybody's favorite bald streamer
look at what i'm [ __ ] dealing with
listen
thank you [ __ ] look me in the
eyes
when you're trying to greet me little
[ __ ] [ __ ]
back me out i'm not playing this one
back me out the game was created by
indie developer media tonic with the
idea forming from a random comment in a
pitch meeting
poor guys itself like all the best ideas
came when we were talking about
something else
entirely and then midway through uh joe
walsh the lead design on project
was just like oh you know what this
sounds a little bit like takeshi's
castle
total wipeout all of these things and we
were like yeah that's really nice but
we're kind of talking about this game
right now
and then he went away and a day later
he'd come back with this one pager for
four guys which was obviously
the best idea we've had in ages but when
they were making fall guys mediatonic
didn't want their characters to resemble
the athletes from american ninja warrior
or wipeout
they wanted the exact opposite so
there's an old tv show called it's a
knockout
which basically went to a town dressed a
bunch of people up in really ridiculous
outfits which were impossible to move in
and then made them compete in an
obstacle course and we kind of went back
to that and felt that when we were first
designing the full guys
they needed to have that element of
being completely uniquely badly designed
for the task that we were going to put
them through and when the game went into
beta it was a huge success
thanks in part to mediatonic's senior
community manager and social media
phenom
oliver hindell he said at lelo i can
hear you typing
hey yo everyone waving oliver what's up
man
we're live is eight months what up
oliver what up my man what's going on
hey yo we're just giving away some keys
hindu is the guy in charge of fall guys
social media including their million
follower twitter account which has
gotten so big that it's got brands like
kfc and konami
tweeting fan art at them and fall guys's
social media has gotten so popular that
it started a charity bidding war between
these brands with the highest bidder
getting their skin
included in the game hindu also managed
to get some of twitch's biggest
streamers playing the beta this might be
good for the boys
this may be good for the boys we're in
talks this may be
good for the boys no no no no not that
much don't get it don't say a thousand
that's no
who just gave me 69 keys not only did
streamers like sodapop and xqc ms kiff
and lyric get access to the beta but
so did their viewers and from that point
forward
the game would do the talking
first game
become launch day fall guys was hit with
an unexpected crisis
the game was too popular and it just
couldn't handle everyone rushing onto
the servers at once
and fall guys went down for 30 minutes
but all it took was 30 minutes for
pissed off trolls to start review
bombing the game on steam
and it got so bad that mediatonic had to
take to twitter
to just ask everyone to chill out while
they fixed it but once fall guys came
back online that review-bombing nonsense
was drowned out by the massive
amount of people who were in love with
the game this game's this game's coming
back
i'm playing i'm playing this [ __ ] more
oh my god it's so much fun
but okay where does tim come in well
pretty soon after launch
fall guys hit tim's radar and uh safe to
say that
he sucked at it now you're good traffic
traffic just go slow
some [ __ ] [ __ ] who knew a simple
platformer where you play as a goddamn
jelly bean
would be the game to send tim into such
a hilariously
angry tailspin
[Applause]
[ __ ] how is my [ __ ] ass eating two
no worries no worries
this effing wolf jam in its face
dude
time
and as his frustration grew so did the
amount of people tuning in just to see
if he could win a game
i cannot [ __ ] explain
what the [ __ ] is going on what the [ __ ]
i got trouble dude
are you [ __ ] kidding me back me out
i'm not [ __ ] ending like that for
some
fall guys is a quick 15 minutes of fun
during their break
for tim it was a grueling eight-day saga
as he tried to win
a single game
can't even make this up i i can't make
this up right i glitch through the floor
right come on i see it didn't matter
what he did
tim just couldn't [ __ ] do it he
literally got to the finish line at one
point before he got eliminated
where's he where's this other guy matt
he's always at the bottom he's on the
bottom level but he's
oh bro you have so much real estate i
just can't
choke
[Applause]
it didn't matter who he was playing with
it didn't matter what
mini game he was queued up for tim just
couldn't catch a break
and people loved it tim espn is actually
tracking this
what do you mean chat that's i don't
understand
it's been seven days and still know when
we are tracking it here espn.com
are you [ __ ] kidding me it was a saga
that by the end had
hundreds of thousands of people popping
off as a grown-ass man
finally won his jelly bean creature a
crown
this is you one on one tim timmy go this
nice and easy let's go
you said it gonna be done there's the
king
put my crown on
give me the crown oh finally
against all odds dude oh my gosh
oh god legacy tim let's go
oh dude i can't believe it
hell tim's single win was so big that he
was trending on twitter by the end of it
against all odds
we persevered it looked hot
there were tough times that we went
through
highs and lows but the most important
thing is we were all together
cheers regardless of the way it's played
fall guys sits at the top of
gaming and mediatonic didn't rely on
some grandiose marketing
campaign or some giant publisher to help
them out
if they had maybe those 30 minutes of
launch day issues would have happened
very differently and maybe the saga of
tim
never would have happened at all chat
just like i never gave up
you never gave up fall guys creates
those where were you when
moments that we all crave and it built a
relationship with the community that
both loves the game
and the vibe that it creates
a vibe that's paid off more than anyone
could have imagined
you